gilbert casasus bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france on lisait le chancelier
autrichien sebastian course a donc
annoncé ne se passe wit est d'accueillir
plus d'avant que plus d'afghans comment
est ce que vous comprenez ce choix je
comprends ce choix pour des raisons de
politique intérieure autrichienne
monsieur sebastian course et un
chancelier droite une droite dure et
donc conformément à son idéologie
confirmant conformément à ses
convictions qui sont des convictions
extrêmement consommatrice de secours est
dans la ligne de cette droite européenne
que l'on retrouve aussi en france que
l'on retrouve aussi en slovénie que la
retrouve aussi en pologne que l'on
retrouve aussi en hongrie donc ces pays
d'europe centrale sont des pays
aujourd'hui vous dirai très influencé
voire miné par une idéologie de repli
sur soi même et rien d'étonnant à voir
quelqu'un qui a aussi flirté durant sa
jeunesse avec des associations
étudiantes qui ne fait pas des plus
démocratiques du monde puisse
aujourd'hui prend une telle position
le christ et pourtant le pays d'europe
avec la plus forte communauté afghane 1
40 mille ressortissants
reporter à sa population est-ce que
l'autriche considère aussi finalement
qu'elle a pris sa part en terme
d'accueil elle peut prendre cette
position qui lui qui fit il faut savoir
que l'autriche et à payer un peu
compliqué très peu connu d'ailleurs en
france parce que il ya toujours une
différence entre une autriche biennoise
viennent et je dirais le reste de
l'autriche voir l'autriche
agricole et plus campagnarde quand vous
regardez les élections c'est extrêmement
intéressant à voir que dans les centres
urbains il ya une présence de gauche
relativement importante dans les
campagnes là
c'est la droite qui
pré prédominante par exemple tout
tout l'ouest de l'autriche est beaucoup
plus conservateur que l'est de
l'autriche donc il faut savoir ce qui
fait la différence mais bien un point
essentiel c'est que monsieur course ne
va pas seul il gouverne avec les verts
il ya une coalition qui est une
coalition noir vert c'est-à-dire
conservatrice et vertes et les verts l'a
complètement prise au piège parce que
les verts ne peuvent pas dire d'un côté
nous sommes le parti de l'ouverture nous
sommes le parti du respect des droits de
l'homme et d'autre part cautionner une
politique de monsieur courte et la
question de fond c'est de savoir si oui
ou non les verts en autriche vont vendre
leur âme au diable passez moi
l'expression genève a comparu du conseil
diable mais c'est exactement la question
qui se pose et il ya une crise politique
intérieure qui pourraient éclater cnl
n'éclate pas c'est que les verts ont
perdu toute crédibilité morale en
autriche liées aussi cette affaire
léonie cette petite fille de 13 ans qui
avait été droguée et violée par quatre
individus d'originaires d'afghanistan
est-ce que ce terrible ce terrible drame
a aussi eu un impact finalement sur la
décision du chancelier vous avez tout
tout crime toute forme de criminalité
un impact qui c'est clair mais c'est
toujours braqués sur un événement une
question beaucoup plus fondamental c'est
très facile au niveau politique c'est
beaucoup moins facile au niveau de la
traitement d'un dossier
j'écoutais aussi votre reportage par
rapport à ce front cet avenant qu'on a
arrêté avec raison en france il ya
toujours des brebis game ya toujours un
cas particulier et tout tout l'art de la
politique serait de faire abstraction
des cas particuliers pour servir
l'intérêt général l'a vécu dans une
tradition très rousseauiste mais à
première vue aujourd'hui notamment dont
chez certains
mouvement politique au sein de certaines
familles politiques le cas particulier
semble l'emporter sur le cas général et
ce n'est pas comme ça que la politique
annonce il ya des cas aussi comme
l'attentât islamiste du 2 novembre 2020
en autriche qui ont aussi un impact très
fort sur la population oui et c'était il
ya quelques ans même d'intégrer dans
l'autrichien dans qu'il faut aussi faire
très attention avec ces questions là je
pense qu'il faut rester
un peu serein qu'il ne faut pas tirer
des conclusions trop hâtives et d'un
côté on prend un cas particulier pour en
faire une généralité d'autre part il ne
faut surtout pas tomber non plus dans un
langage que vous lirez naïf en disant
que
cette question n'existe pas et qu'il ne
mérite pas d'être traité en effet
l'autriche a été confrontée au
terrorisme islamique et c'est terrorisme
là il les doit être combattu mais il
doit être combattu aussi en toute
connaissance de cause et tant à gauche
qu'à droite et je pense notamment dans
un certain discours des verts ou six
allemands aussi autrichien il ya parfois
un peu de naïveté le très mauvaise
compréhension de ce phénomène là merci à
vous merci beaucoup gilbert casasus
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
sur rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
professeur en études européennes auprès
de la faculté des lettres de
l'université de fribourg